Forester, not garage owner.
Here,
the jobs attention,
what are the intended jobs?
These are the jobs in which
working conditions are unbearable
and salaries are online,
it's clear, it's,
it's in the building industry,
it's in the restaurant,
running all night,
do the crazy,
and in the mornings,
you disappear,
you disappear.
It is in the hotels,
making the rooms,
beds,
it'spost warehouses
or any
logistics,
to unload the trucks thoroughly,
or even behind 1 garbage truck to be emptied
all all garbage cans
every morning
to do,
to do the cleanings
in trains or even in premises.
That's what jobs are intended,
this job as well.
Why regular people,
whether they are French or of foreign origin,
don't want that job?
Because the working conditions are unbearable,
the salaries are unworthy,
people don't want to,
so they want to regularize.
And 1 game of undocumented migrants saying,
you continue to do this work,
if tomorrow they are,
and these,
these jobs are no longer,
beware,
they lose their residence permit,
so it's not equal rights.